oui
[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview
consacrée aujourd'hui aux victimes des
attentats du 13 novembre 2015 à paris
alors que le procès va s'échelonner
durant neuf longs mois ces terribles
actes terroristes ont fait 130 morts des
milliers de blessés de vies brisées de
familles détruites et aujourd'hui les
survivants et leurs proches sont aidés
dans leur difficile reconstruction par
les associations et par l'état bien
évidemment et nous avons parlé de tout
cela avec jérôme moreau merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
alors vous êtes vice président et porte
parole de la fédération france victime
il s'agit d'un réseau d'associations qui
aide les victimes de toute nature que ce
soit par exemple le terrorisme les
cambriolages les violences conjugales
les accidents et je voudrais savoir
comment vous avez abordé comme vous
abordez ce procès historique
alors effectivement procès historique
puisque c'est un procédure en vigueur
qui n'a jamais eu lieu en france il faut
déjà le préciser et nous l'avons aborder
très sereinement
avec rigueur c'est à dire que nous avons
participé notamment paris aide aux
victimes qui est l'association phare de
la fédération sur ce procès eh bien nous
allons participer à l'organisation tout
d'abord à des séances de travail avec
les juridictions et puis avec les
victimes bien entendu pour les
accompagner jusqu'au cheminement de ce
procès qui va s'ouvrir le
il vit septembre et pour leur permettre
d'aborder ce procès dans des conditions
les plus favorables possibles dans le
cadre quand même d'un procès qui va être
très dur pour elle alors justement il y
à de nombreuses de conditions qui ont
été mises en place pour que tout se
passe bien lors au niveau évidemment du
rendu de la justice mais également de
l'attention de l'aide apportée aux
victimes avec un accompagnement
psychologique par exemple vous pouvez
nous parler de toutes ces mesures qui
ont été mises en place alors tout
d'abord c'est une salle d'audiences
spécifiques il faut le préciser qui a
été construit spécifiquement pour le
procès 750 m² 600 personnes qui vont
pouvoir intégrer cette salle d'audience
dix autres salles
autour de cette salle d'audience pour
permettre au maximum de personnes de
pouvoir assister au procès alors
effectivement toutes les victimes
pourront pas rentrer dans la salle
d'audience mais on va faire un espèce de
tourner over si on peut dire comme ça au
moment de leur déposition au moment de
la plaidoirie leurs avocats en tout cas
tout est organisé et normalisé pour elle
la deuxième chose c'est que nous avons
préparé les victimes bien évidemment
paris et de victimes a
organisé des visites sur les lieux ce
qui est extrêmement important puisqu'on
va pouvoir voir que dans cette ancienne
cour d'appel de paris eh bien on a une
salle très solennelle mais il faut les
mettre à l'aise les victimes et puis on
prépare les victimes à témoigner pour
celles qui le souhaitent on prépare les
victimes aussi à pouvoir écouter le
procès puisque pour la première fois le
procès sera équipée d'une webradio donc
on va peut-être en parlais tout à
l'heure mais en tout cas ils auront un
code spécifique elles pourront suivre
deux chez elle parce que vous l'avez 19
mois c'est très long et donc l'attend
pas pouvoir assister à toutes les
audiences tout le temps donc voilà et
puis effectivement un étayage
psychologique très important
tout d'abord dans le palais de justice
puisque paris de victimes à 18 personnes
12e psychologue et puis toutes les
associations c'est à dire les 130
associations pour le terrain sont
mobilisés savent qu'à tout moment elles
peuvent accueillir
une victime qui de chez elle
s'effondrerait qui de chézelles
éprouveraient le besoin de revenir sur
ce qu'elle a subi ce qu'elle a traversé
et donc tout le réseau les 130
associations
métropolitaine et ultramarine sont
mobilisés bien évidemment autour de la
fédération et autour de paris de
victimes pour accompagner au mieux ses
victimes c'est dire que vous avez
préparé la prise de parole d'un
psychologue ou quelqu'un qui qui lui a
peut-être expliquer comment elle allait
se produire ce qu'elle allait peut-être
dire c'est ce genre de préparation alors
effectivement on leur a expliqué comment
allait se dérouler l'audience d'abord
parce que c'est d'abord eu encore une
fois une audience extrêmement longue
donc c'est pas banal le rôle des avocats
est essentiel aussi bien puisque quand
elles vont déposer il va falloir
qu'elle sache ce qu'elles veulent dire
est ce qu'elles veulent exprimer et ça
aussi c'est une préparation en lien avec
les associations les avocats et les
victimes bien évidemment et puis après
effectivement ça va raviver très
certainement des souvenirs extrêmement
douloureux donc mais ça on va les
accompagner au jour le jour parce que on
sait faire je disais qu'ils avaient 1800
participants
mais certaines victimes n'ont pas voulu
se constituer en fait comme si elle
souhaitait tourner la page est ce que
c'est fréquent en tout cas pour celles
qui se sont constitués parties civiles
quel est le rôle de ce procès alors je
crois que les victimes attendent trois
choses pour celles qui se sont
constituées parties civiles
tout d'abord
de pouvoir témoigner de pouvoir dire les
choses et c'est extrêmement important de
pouvoir le dire dans une enceinte qui
représente les institutions qu'ils
représentent la nation une exigence de
vérité bien évidemment alors est-ce que
le principal survivants auteurs parlera
salade et slam c'est tout l'enjeu aussi
et je crois que ce sera un des temps
fort du procès et puis une exigence de
justice et une condamnation exemplaire
il faut le rappeler quand même par cette
cour spécialement composée
des peines extrêmement lourdes et puis
certaines datant de rien et j'y mettrai
celles qui se sont constitués parties
civiles et celles qui ne se sont pas
constitués partie civile parce que
effectivement certaines ont tourné la
page certaines ne veulent plus en parler
en direct et nous ça va on a réussi à
remonter la pente on a réussi à faire
notre deuil
à nourrir des blessures voilà donc
laissez nous tranquilles tout cela en
tout cas ne se juge pas ne se commande
pas et chaque victime va trouver en
elle-même les possibilités de faire
preuve de résilience à son rythme et
selon ce qu'elle souhaite et alors vous
france victime la fédération comment
at-elle agi juste après les attentats
parce qu'on a parlé de l'aide que vous
avez apportée aux victimes qui vont se
présenter mais juste après alors
évidemment au moment de la crise
nous avons été diligentée mobilisés par
le ministère des affaires étrangères et
le ministère de l'intérieur nous étions
tout de suite dans les cellules de crise
au niveau ministériel le réseau a été
immédiatement mobilisé nous avons tout
de suite envoyé des notes aux
associations en disant attention toute
la france est susceptible d'avoir des
victimes d'infractions la première chose
qu'on a faite c'est accompagné
accueillir les victimes dont elle
voulait bien que nous les accompagnons
bien évidemment par un accompagnement
psychologique tout d'abord c'était la
première chose débriefer et puis nous
avons donné au fur et à mesure toutes
les informations en notre possession à
toutes les victimes au fur et à mesure
de
l'instruction et puis nous les avons
accompagnés au procès je veux aussi
souligner que l'accompagnement
effectivement de la crise jusqu'au
procès a été une première étape le
procès constituera une seconde étape et
puis après parce qu'il y aura un après
procès eh bien il va falloir que les
victimes qui n'ont toujours pas tourné
la page parce qu'elle attend de ce
procès parce qu'elle espère un certain
nombre d'éléments parce qu'elle espère
un serbe de choses et bien là il va
falloir que les victimes entament ce
long et douloureux processus également
de reconstruction mais ça sera après le
procès et la va se nommait encore
d'autres choses donc nous les avons nous
allons les accompagner du début de la
crise jusqu'à leur reconstruction tant
est que ce soit possible pour certaines
et combien de personnes avez vous aidé
3050 sur uniquement c'est les attentats
du 13 novembre
en tout à l'heure actuelle pour vous
donner une idée avec les attentats du 14
juillet de nice et puis les différents
attentats qui ont émaillé
malheureusement la france après nous
sommes à plus de 7000 victimes donc nous
avons une vraie expérience une vraie
expertise j'ai envie de dire bien malgré
nous et bien malheureusement sur ces
questions mais c'est aussi la force d'un
réseau de 130 associations et d'une
fédération alors comment viennent vers
vous est ce que vous attendez qu'elle
vous contacter ou est ce que c'est vous
qui allez au devant d'elle et après vous
les répertorier comment ça se traite
alors nous avons eu tout de suite les
listes des victimes à la suite des
attentats du 13 novembre toutes les
victimes blessées bien évidemment toutes
les cordes des familles endeuillées bien
évidemment et puis nous avons accueilli
également toutes les victimes
qui étaient plus ou moins concernés au
sens juridique
strict par part par les attentats mais
qui ont éprouvé le besoin d'avoir des
accompagnements parce qu'il connaissait
quelqu'un de très proche parce qu' il
n'était pas très loin parce qu'ils
avaient assisté
aux scènes et donc nous avons considéré
que la notion de victime était
extrêmement élargie et que toute
personne qui avait besoin d'un
accompagnement devait être accompagné
c'est ça qui fait aussi je crois notre
différence de distinction avec un
certain nombre d'institutions c'est que
nous n'avons justement pas sélectionner
toutes les victimes dont nous avions les
coordonnées bien évidemment nous les
avons accompagnés et nous les avons
contactés et nous restons en lien avec
elle et puis un certain nombre de
personnes sont venues et donc toutes ces
personnes nous les avons bien évidemment
accompagné et nous poursuivons
l'accompagnement tenté qu'elle en est
encore besoin si énormément de choses
qui reviennent ce comme vous dites une
sorte de définition élargie à la victime
ça peut être sûr qu'aucun témoin oui
bien sûr pour vous ça peut être un
témoin ou quelqu'un qui a été
extrêmement gravement blessé ou un
parent qu'est ce qui les rassemble
toutes ses victimes ce qui les rassemble
c'est l'événement malheureusement c'est
le fait que des attentats terroristes et
eu lieu ce soir du 13 novembre dans
différentes parties du territoire et
qu'elles étaient touchés par ce
phénomène infractionnel
ce qu'ils croient qu est ce qu elle
alors entretien est ce qu'elles disent
c'est pourquoi moi
comment est ce qu'on a pu en arriver là
n'y avait-il pas besoin d'éviter ce
drame voilà et puis il ya ce que toute
famille endeuillée par un acte criminel
exprime c'est une douleur immense bien
évidemment c'est la perte d'un être cher
et c'est comment est ce qu'on va pouvoir
tourner la page comment est ce qu'on
peut faire face à cela donc autant de
questions sur lesquelles il est parfois
difficile de poser des mots mais qu'il
faut tout d'abord écouté et puis après
il faut parler dialoguer ça c'est tout
le rôle des psychologues que
d'accompagner pour les préparer au
procès et puis après pour les préparer
après ce procès justement à faire cette
oeuvre de reconstruction mais ce qui
l'est c'est ce qui les unit encore une
fois c'est ce cet acte terroriste
extrêmement violent extrêmement brutale
et qui a sidéré en fin de compte j'en
veux dire notre pays surtout qu'à de
multiples traumatismes parce qu'elle a
la douleur physique bien sûr les
blessures mais il ya aussi la tente il
ya une très nombreux attentats lors soit
dans le bataclan ou alors avant que les
terrains soient sécurisés donc les
victimes sont restées sur place parfois
pendant une heure deux heures ou plus ça
se traduit comment vous récupérez des
victimes qui sont dans quel état
psychique alors à l'époque ce qu'on peut
dire c'est qu'on avait des victimes qui
étaient comme fortement traumatisées ont
dit gravement traumatisées effectivement
vous avez raison il ya eu les victimes
dont un membre de la famille est décédé
on a eu effectivement ceux qui ont eu
des balles et qui ont été atteints dans
leur chair 1 et puis on a eu toutes les
victimes survivantes date où ces
attentats donc il faut prendre en compte
tout ça alors les soins évidemment c'est
la médecine nous nous occupons plutôt de
l'accompagnement psychologique de
l'accompagnement social aussi parce que
certaines victimes n'ont pas pu
reprendre le travail certaines victimes
éprouvent des difficultés tout
simplement à sortir chez elle donc tout
cela il faut le prendre en compte et il
faut ouvrir des droits est évidemment
parle beaucoup de l'accompagnement
psychologique mais
chants d'accompagnement autre à côté
encore une fois l'indemnisation qui est
extrêmement importante pour ces
personnes on en parlera et puis aussi
pour celles qui sont handicapés il faut
complètement changé de cadre de vie
voilà il faut c'est une révolution suite
à un acte encore une fois terroriste et
il faut les accompagner et c'est notre
votre job et puis bien évidemment il ya
tout l'accompagnement juridique
parce que on a ce procès qui arrive et
là encore il a fallu monter les dossiers
d'indemnisation d'un côté et puis là il
faut permettre aux victimes qui se
constitue partie civile d'avoir tout ce
qu'elles ont besoin alors aujourd'hui
évidemment à quelques encablures de
l'audience juridiquement tout est fait
sauf que quand même jusqu aux
réquisitions du parquet national anti
terroriste toute victime qui s'est pas
encore constituées parties civiles le
pourra et ça c'est aussi notre rôle de
les accompagner mais en tout état de
cause c'est un accompagnement
pluridisciplinaire au long cours et dont
on n'a pas terminé et dont on n'en voit
pas la fin est ce qu'on est sûr que tous
les orphelins étaient répertoriés alors
en principe oui ça on a à peu près une
garantie je ne dis pas qu ici ou là on
n'aura pas un incident sur ce plan ce
qui serait vraiment très dommageable
extrêmement préjudiciable mais en
principe toutes les victimes orpheline
effectivement ont été répertoriés ont pu
recevoir le statut de pupille de la
nation pour celle qu'il voulait parce
que quelques unes n'ont pas voulu fos
istres et le respecter un donc voilà
c'est comme ça et mais en tout cas
aujourd'hui en principe tous les enfants
sont accompagnés protéger et sécuriser
leurs droits c'est un moment on va
marquer une courte pause on se retrouve
juste après
[Musique]
de retour avec jérôme moreau vice
président et porte parole de la
fédération france victime à la veille
d'un procès historique le procès des
attentats du 13 novembre 2015 1800
parties civiles des vies détruites
un procès d'une ampleur inégalée juste
ici pour rendre justice à ces très
nombreuses victimes qui souffrent dans
leur chair et dans leur psychisme alors
quel est le parcours des victimes et de
leurs proches justement au sujet de
l'indemnisation à particulier alors les
choses se sont rapidement mises en place
puisque effectivement on avait bien
compris que le procès serait quand même
pas rapide
malgré le fait quand même que on est six
ans après donc pour un procès du aussi
considérable ces essais relativement
rapide mais on a rapidement compris
qu'il fallait à des musées des victimes
donc le fonds de garantie
ces mises en place et a permis une
indemnisation des victimes
dès lors qu'elle rentrait dans un
certain nombre de critères donc c'est
pourquoi aujourd'hui la juridiction
spécialement composée la cour d'assises
spécialement composée ne permettra pas
une ouverture d'indemnisation puisqu'en
principe les victimes ont pu être
indemnisés alors avec un avec avec à 10
voilà avec un mécanisme de fonds de
garantie à tout le monde le connaît
puisque sur ces contrats d'assurance
vous allez voir une ligne 3 3 euros et
quelques pour le fonds de garantie donc
qui signifie que tout le monde cotise
pour se font toutes les
et personnes qui ont une assurance
effectivement cotisent pour ce fonds
c'est un fonds de solidarité et on voit
bien qu'aujourd'hui on avait besoin
parce que vous imaginez bien
qu'aujourd'hui de toute manière quoi
qu'il arrive les auteurs
qui sont au nombre de 20 déjà il n'a que
quatorze qui comparaissent vous pensez
bien qu'il ne pourront indemniser
l'intégralité des victimes et qu'ils ne
pourront rembourser l'avancé des frais
fait par les caisses de sécurité sociale
à ce moment là donc le droit français
est extrêmement protecteur est
extrêmement bien fait et a prévu un
mécanisme de fonds de garantie donc
aujourd'hui les victimes ont reçu une
indemnisation alors l'indemnisation ne
vaut pas réparation intégrale puisque
pour nous la réparation intégrale c'est
la restauration y compris
psychique et psychologique
et dans l'intégralité des dignes de sa
dignité est ce qu'une victime de
terrorisme est davantage indemniser
qu'un autre type de victime alors
j'ai ouvert une réponse de normand où
est donc en principe non puisque on
répare intégralement le préjudice et que
le préjudice donc il n'y a pas de raison
d'aller au delà en revanche on sait
quand même qu'on a eu des barèmes de
l'émulation extrêmement important du
fait de l'ampleur tout d'abord du nombre
de victimes du fait de la
caractéristique de ces victimes alors
effectivement à certaines associations
de victimes plaide pour un préjudice
anormal et spécial
qui pourrait être donné à ses victimes
aujourd'hui on peut dire que en tout
état de cause les victimes ont été
indemnisées de manière à peu près
correcte selon les critères du droit
français la seule chose quand même
puisqu'on en parle et leurs antennes se
sont toutes les personnes qui sont en
situation de handicap et qui ont perdu
leur emploi et là effectivement ce n'est
pas le tout d'indemniser il va falloir
retrouver une vie encore une fois qu'ils
soient à peu près celle de la personne
avant le avant l'attentât ce qui est
pratiquement vieux puits pour nous on le
sait mais en tout cas il faut les sortir
du statut de victime et là il ya tout un
enjeu et je pense qu' il faudrait que
les maisons départementales des
personnes handicapées soient beaucoup
plus mobilisés et davantage aux côtés
des victimes par rapport à cela combien
de personnes ont été indemnisées justice
alors là alors j'ai pas les chiffres
exacts mais on a plusieurs milliers de
personnes sur l'ensemble des attentats
que ce soit nice où les attentats du 13
du 13 novembre jeudi est volontairement
les attentats du 13 novembre parce que
on a plutôt tendance à les réduire sur
le bataclan mais on a eu le stade de
foot on a eu les cafés on a eu toute
cette cabale là-dedans paris donc il
faut vraiment que c'est du bataclan de
toutes les deux de tout sens de cette
soirée-là extrêmement difficile jusqu'à
la chute en belgique deux salles
abdeslam donc voilà donc on a beaucoup
de victimes et qui sont aussi en dehors
du bataclan même si c'est le bataclan
évidemment il a connu les plus lourdes
pertes et où il ya eu le plus de
victimes blessées et tuées mais on a
bien d'autres et toutes ces victimes là
doivent être aussi également
indemniser de manière équitable parce
que voilà on a focalisé beaucoup sur un
point mais il y à bien d'autres points
dans paris parce que tu avais toutes
n'ont pas été encore indemnisées
puisqu'il faut que leur état soit
consolidé alors tradi jusqu'à quand elle
les procédures vous monsieur alors là ce
sont des procédures médicales 1 ce sont
les expertises qui vont le dire en tout
cas il ya des avances sur provisions qui
peuvent être faites et il est il a été
important pour nous de ne pas laisser
une victime en tout cas dans la
précarité financière ça c'est évident
alors effectivement la consolidation on
peut prendre du temps
effectivement c'est un processus qui est
long c'est un par exemple sur les
accidents de la circulation ça peut
prendre dix ans donc bon on espère que
là ça prendra pas dix ans mais en tout
cas effectivement ce sont les expertises
là qui vont nous guider et donc moi je
peux pas dire médicalement je suis pas
médecin d'abord donc voilà donc je peux
pas dire quand est ce que tout sera
consolidée mais en tout cas les
expertises qui sont plutôt
objective
parce que il faut aussi rassurer les
gens les expertises ont été bien fait
les les préjudices ont été bien
appréhendée donc on aura des
indemnisations vous voyez moi la
première chose que j'ai faite pour les
victimes dans la nièvre c'est de leur
faire un test auditif parce qu'avec les
impacts de balles dans le bataclan on ne
savait pas à l'époque si oui ou non
l'audition les dégradés donc au moins
les a protégés comme cela donc
effectivement ça peut se déclarer cinq
six sept ans plus tard donc voilà mais
ça c'est malheureusement aussi un long
processus beaucoup trop long pour les
victimes mais en tout cas qui est
nécessaire pour les indemniser
correctement et pour les protéger vous
parlez des expertises qui ont été bien
faites expertise médicale mais on a
entendu énormément de victimes aussi se
plaindre de la relation avec l'expert
disons avec selon elle parfois une
volonté de minorer leurs épreuves leur
souffrance ou le décalage entre leur vie
d'avant et la vie empreinte de
souffrance est ce que vous avez eu de
tels retours de la part d'eads estime
que vous suivez bien évidemment
les alors tout d'abord il faut dire que
l' expertise est un moment très
douloureux pour les victimes quelles que
soient les victimes d'infractions donc
évidemment que nous avons eues ces
retours là
si nous n'étions pas contents nous leur
avons indiqué qu'il y avait une
possibilité de contre expertise c'est
parce que voilà il n'y a pas qu'un
expert quand même il ya comme des
procédures qui permettent aussi de
protéger le droit des victimes et il
faut qu elle en use et je vais m'en veut
dire qu'il faut que j'en abuse si les
victimes s'estime à satisfaites sur une
expertise donc effectivement et puis
alors après effectivement
la problématique va être quel prix
va-t-on assigné à la douleur et comment
va-t-on à démoniser le préjudice moral
et ça c'est toujours quelque chose qui
est très difficile à appréhender pour
une personne parce qu'on va même lui
demander de dire mais quel prix vaut
votre fille quel prix votre père et
c'est impossible c'est un débat
impossible pour les victimes donc
effectivement
nous avons eu ces essais s'est ressenti
des victimes qui sont légitimes
d'ailleurs qu'il faut entendre et qu'il
faut corriger quand il ya besoin pour
augmenter les indemnisations si
nécessaire il ya aussi s'est fait
scandale évidemment c'est très abject
des personnes qui se sont fait passer
pour des petits mais qui ont ensuite ont
été repérés qu'est ce qui s'est produit
est ce qu'on les a toutes identiques
l'heure je ne sais pas sur les a toutes
identifiées mais celle qui est
identifiée ont été sévèrement condamnée
et c'est quand même tendu alors il
existait un secrétariat général des deux
victimes qui a été mise en place après
les attentats
hollande voilà finalement minel macron
la supprimer
comment on explique cette décision alors
en fait il a vu un des propos qui avait
fâché les associations de victimes en
disant qu'il fallait en finir avec la
politique victimaire comment vous
expliquez cela est ce que pour autant ça
empêche les victimes d'être suivi alors
non sur le terrain non puisque nous
agissons nous faisons notre fils et nous
les accompagnons en revanche
effectivement nous avions considéré au
départ que c'était plutôt un mauvais
message de supprimer ce secrétariat à
l'aide aux victimes et de le remplacer
par une déléguée interministérielle à
l'aide aux victimes chemin faisant ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que
l'expérimentation de cette déléguée
interministérielle
a été plutôt dans la continuité de cette
secrétaire d'état sauf que quand même
lorsqu'on a un poste de ministre et
lorsqu'on est délégué interministériel
les choses institutionnellement sont
différents et effectivement c'est un
curseur différent qui est mis après
je ne me permettrais pas de commenter le
discours du président de la république
mais simplement dire que nous ne sommes
pas dans une politique victimaire
aujourd'hui sont dans une politique d'
aide aux victimes c'est un petit peu
différent parce que tout l'objet des
associations d'aidé aux victimes c'est
justement de sortir d'une victimisation
accrue est trop importante est de faire
en sorte qu'elle sort de ce statut de
victime et je crois quand même que le
secrétariat d'état à l'aide aux victimes
où les délégué interministériel de
victimes doivent s'inspirer de notre
philosophie
justement peut-être pour rectifier le
tir ou l'ajuster il ya une concertation
sur l'accompagnement et l'indemnisation
des victimes de terrorisme qui a été
mise en place par la déléguée
interministérielle dame calandra à votre
avis est ce que c'est pour réussir à
mieux suivre en tout cas à ne pas donner
prise aux critiques je sais pas
tout ce que je sais c'est que l'arrivée
et des procès
les reportages que vous faites tous ici
ou là et qui nous ont aussi aidé il faut
le dire
parce que ça a été aussi des attentes on
n'a pas parlé mais on a parlé beaucoup
des victimes individuelle et c'est tant
mieux mais est aussi une victime dont on
ne parle pas c'est la nation atteinte
dans ses valeurs démocratiques et
républicaines
et quand on voit ce qui se passe quand
même je reprendrai uniquement
l'afghanistan aujourd'hui sur la place
des femmes sur le rôle de la presse
voilà aujourd'hui on peut dire aussi
qu'en france heureusement que vous avez
été là les médias pour mettre en lumière
tout cela est vrai des petits
dysfonctionnements et qui ensuite ont
été identifiés et puis vous avez mis
aussi la lumière sur des victimes quand
même et sur des choses qui étaient d'une
ampleur considérable
vous allez couvrir ce procès vous avez
accepté la presse qu'on ait des cordons
verts et des cordes rouge pour celles
qui voulaient parler celle qui ne
voulait pas vous êtes vraiment engagé à
respecter aussi cette dignité donc voilà
c'est tout ce que les démocraties fait
et ce que les dictatures ne font pas est
ce que ceux qui sont dans les bancs des
accusés ne ferons pas et ne partage pas
donc voilà enfin pour revenir sur votre
question sur
pourquoi est-ce qu'on travail est
entrepris par la déléguée
interministérielle
certainement qu'aujourd'hui les victimes
de terrorisme constitue
sans doute le paradigme de la victime
qu'il faut accompagner aujourd'hui nous
considérons qu effectivement
il est de notre devoir de notre rôle de
les accompagner mais nous avons aussi
d'autres victimes gravement traumatisées
sur le territoire je pense aux victimes
de viol je pense aux victimes d'inceste
je pense aux victimes de violences
conjugales je pense même aux victimes
d'accidents de la route qui sont
polytraumatisés et bien nous les
accompagnons également et donc ne soyons
plutôt favorable à
réfléchir à la question de
l'indemnisation aujourd'hui général des
victimes et à des mécanismes beaucoup
plus fluide d'indemnisation et je parle
notamment des mdph je crois que elles
aussi ont un rôle à jouer mais en effet
bien plus est ce qu on entend très
souvent de la part des victimes qui sont
de plus en plus nombreuses à signaler
sur les réseaux sociaux que ce soit en
effet l'inceste violences conjugales et
pour finir on va parler peut-être de la
dimension politique de ce procès ce que
vous craignez de votre côté a vraiment
des associations que ce procès soit
instrumentalisée puisque la sécurité est
un des enjeux majeurs de la future
campagne présidentielle
alors
d'abord on a cinq magistrats
expérimentés trois magistrats du parquet
national anti terroriste donc une cour
spécialement composée qui sera et
répondre en tout cas c'est pas dans
l'enceinte de ce procès que
l'instrumentalisation se frappe c'est
pas de notre côté non plus on en soit
rassuré après effectivement on voit bien
que selon qu'on soit plus ou moins
sécuritaire on va dire voilà tout le
monde aura compris on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui il va y avoir des
exigences ce procès va durer neuf mois
il va se terminer à quelques encablures
de
la présidentielle donc voilà en tout cas
ce serait extrêmement dommage et ça
serait vraiment ne pas rendre service
aux victimes c'est un certain nombre de
partis politiques étaient mal
intentionnés et viendrait
instrumentaliser ce procès en tout cas
en tant que porte parole
je ne dénoncerai parce que c'est un
procès pour les victimes c'est un procès
également pour la république et il ne
s'agit de rien d'autre que de juger des
hommes qui ont commis un attentat sur le
territoire qui doivent être condamnées
qui doivent être sévèrement condamné le
droit français est suffisamment bien
fait pour qu'on instrumentalise pas ce
procès et qu'on n'embarque pas les
victimes encore dans des labyrinthes
dont elles n'ont pas besoin je remercie
beaucoup au moment où c'était les mots
de la fin je vous remercie et je
rappelle que vous êtes donc porte parole
et vice président de la fédération
france victime que vous suivez et aider
les victimes des attentats du 13
novembre 2015 vous remercie d'avoir
suivi cette émission que vous pourrez
retrouver en intégralité sur rtl france
point tv merci de votre fidélité à
bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]